if a creator explains his intent but
nobody gets it
is it still art hey everybody this is a
topic that I have been meaning to do and
sort of have been thinking about
percolating on for a little while and
the date that I am putting this out and
timing of it is has led me to decide to
sort of do that thing that I very rarely
do we just sort of integrate the two
sides of my life so what that means is
that for this video and for the purposes
of it you're gonna see me a little bit
different because if you've never seen
my Q&A in Q&A video this might be news
to you but my name is Nathaniel and my
personal sense of gender does not stay
put a kind of wavers and wanders so I am
presenting this way because today is
national law it's not even national it's
might even be international a blow it's
it's it's the transgender day visibility
I suppose a quick bit of definitions a
different people use transgender in
different ways some people use it as a
blanket term for basically anyone who
does not rigidly define themselves as
cisgender ie you know identifying as the
sex that you were biologically born into
others use it very specifically to mean
someone who was actually transitioning
from one from the sex they were born as
to another and that is not me like I
said my my sense of gender just kind of
meanders around it doesn't really stay
put but I because of the occasion I
thought it was finally time to pull the
trigger on talking about creator intent
how much does it matter what initially
got me thinking about this was something
that I've actually already talked about
which was the whole thing we
it being revealed that the upcoming
sequel to fantastic beasts and where to
find them
is not going to directly address the
fact that Dumbledore had a homosexual
attraction and love for the villain
character of Grindelwald that'll be
that's part of their past at the time
this movie will be set and this is
something that we know JK Rowling has
said this but it's yet to appear
actually in the text it was not
specifically ever referenced in the
books and now even those the even though
there's a movie coming out with both
these characters and it's still not
going to be explicitly stated which is
something that has been upsetting for
many LGBTQ fans of Harry Potter because
it feels like they they're not they
don't have the strength of their own
convinced conviction and they're not
backing up you know what they said the
thing was I don't want to rehash all of
that here now but it's it's what got me
thinking because I have no doubt that it
was never the intent of Rowling or David
Yates who's the director on these films
it was never their intent to cause
distress for LGBTQ fans I'm sure it was
never in their minds that they that they
that what they were doing was going to
be seen by LGBTQ fans as failing to
represent them but it kind of doesn't
matter if that was their intent or not
because that's how it looks and that's
how it reads and there's a funny thing
about intent because I don't always find
it useful I actually very rarely get
excessively hung up on intent they said
the only time that I try and figure out
a creator or a writer or directors
intent behind something is if I just
can't figure it out like if I if I watch
a movie or a TV show and I go what was
that I'll look I'll look up what I can
find about the intent to see if I can
figure you know make heads or tails of
it but if I come away from something
feeling like I've come away with an
experience and this was my experience it
usually doesn't matter
me too much what the intended experience
was and interestingly sort of moving
away for a moment from you know the sort
of more controversial stuff you know
LGBTQ issues and interpretations and and
and intent around that and just talking
more geeky stuff which is more the
wheelhouse of this channel I have run
into this argument with people regarding
a number of movies a couple of zack
snyder movies like sucker punch and
Batman V Superman and also the last Jedi
which I'll cite as well because I don't
want you to think I'm just picking on
Zack Snyder but I've seen a number of
arguments very good ones very well
realized I've seen whole video essays
explaining the intent and the meaning
and what the goals and why things were
the way they were for films like Batman
V Superman the last Jedi and I can read
those and go you know what you're
probably right that that was what they
were trying for I would say it doesn't
matter what they were trying for because
what they delivered didn't work and I've
used the I'm gonna use an analogy that
I've used in a number of other places I
don't think I've done it on video before
so let's oh let me get it on the record
here and that is that I tend to think of
it in those situations where significant
portions if not the majority of
audiences appear to have come away with
an experience that was not the
experience intended to be had by the
creators I tend to liken it to say you
are a comedian and you tell a joke you
know to a group and nobody laughs but
you know it's a good joke I mean you
know exactly how it works and why it's
funny and but nobody laughed and so what
you then do is you you do what they say
kills comedy but you explain it you
explain the joke look here's why it's
funny here was this and this and now
it's this and the audience goes oh okay
yeah yeah that is funny I guess and
maybe you've explained how the thing
that you did
was in fact funny but it doesn't matter
because they didn't laugh when you told
it if it only works after being
explained that to me unless you're
deliberately trying to be obtuse then
that is a failure of the delivery method
and that to me like again to go back to
the joke analogy you probably told the
joke wrong it could very well be funny
in its construction and on paper and in
theory but if nobody laughed maybe he
didn't set it up right maybe there was a
detail you left out that was a big part
of what brought up the humor maybe you
accidentally spoil the punchline before
you got there but if nobody laughed
something went wrong but of course
that's where the arguments tend to come
in with one side saying well it's the
audience's fault for not getting it and
the other side saying it's the it's the
communicators fault for not doing their
part well and as with so many things as
with my gender I tend to fall more in
the middle which is that I think more
often than not when a piece of art be it
a movie or a book or comic or whatever
is taken in a way that was not what the
original creator intended it is usually
a mix of the creator or not being I'm
completely clear with what they were
trying to do and the audience possibly
not being on the same same wavelength as
that so like for myself there are things
that I have watched things that I've
seen that I know for me I just came at
them from the wrong headspace and that
and there are times that I know flat-out
that is not on the Creator that's on me
so like if this is the only example I
can come up with off the top of my head
but let when they when they debuted the
costume for Jodie Whittaker
playing the doctor on Doctor Who my my
thing that I immediately thought of was
Mork for Mork and Mindy
because of the combination of the colors
and the cysts and the suspenders or
braces if you're in the UK but I know
that's not what was intended and I know
that's just me because that's my baggage
that's my cultural reference point
that's what I experienced but I also
know it wasn't what was intended and I'm
coming at it from an angle that is not
the angle it was intended to be come out
from so that is a case where that's on
me but then you know you've got stuff
where people say things that or you know
put out pieces of art that are that
failed to connect that are supposed to
be funny but art are supposed to be
scary but art and I think to a certain
degree you end up with creators who are
overly defensive because if you've put
something out and people are not taking
it the way you intended them to
sometimes it's easier to just go well
you people didn't get it you're the
problem rather than look inside and go
crap did I screw this up with how I put
it out there but the other thing is
ultimately the end of the day I honestly
don't think creator intent matters very
much it matters academically it matters
if you want to better understand the
function of a piece of art it matters if
you if you personally wish to better
understand the thought process and the
mentality of the artist who created it
and sometimes that can lead to a better
understanding of the art I would say not
always but sometimes it can but I don't
think that can or should ever alter your
experience of taking in a piece of art
so an example for me
a piece of art that was massively
important to me the Rocky Horror Picture
Show I know shocking but I saw that
movie when I was 13 years old and I saw
it at a time in my life when I really
kind of needed it and that movie means a
great deal to me because I'm not sure
there's any piece of film that better
exemplifies the concept of let your
freak flag fly and we're all just weird
and it means a lot to me I actually went
to Boston comic-con in 2017 and met Tim
Curry and some of the other cast members
Patricia Quinn al Campbell Barry
Bostwick it was it was really amazing
the reason I bring it up is and some of
the things that he said in more recent
years and over time Richard O'Brien who
played riff raff and also wrote the
original stage play that the movie is
based off of has said a number of things
up in terms of his views on transgender
people that there were a lot to unpack
but they're their notions that were not
things like particularly was comfortable
hearing said by him and again I don't
really want to unpack all that now
because I think in a lot of ways his
views are more complicated than some
people have painted them as but you know
realizing what his feelings on you know
transgender actual transsexual people
PEO people who were born say genetically
a man and firmly identify as a woman or
vice versa that they are not the thing
they identify as that transgender women
are not women that may and knowing that
his is his belief
does bring in the fact that his intent
behind what Rocky Horror Picture Show
means or was meant to mean probably did
not include any sense of validation for
transgender people that was probably in
no way any part of his intent but I
don't care and again I don't identify in
you know transgender in that I'm firmly
you know moving towards one or the other
but I have known more than a few people
who are you know full-on trans actually
living full-time at as the gender that
isn't the one they were born as and this
movie means as much to them as it does
to me and his intent not being to
empower those sorts of people with those
sorts of feeling doesn't matter because
that's what he did and unfortunately
intend not mattering can cut both ways
in that way which I think in some ways
is something we're getting to with an
increased scrutiny of sexual harassment
concerns because a classic excuse and
smokescreen was it was meant as a
compliment I didn't mean any offense you
still hear that one sometimes it doesn't
matter if you meant offense your intent
doesn't matter what you did what you
caused the feelings and emotions that
you caused it on other people that is
not yours to dictate you may have a
preferred emotional reaction that they
have to what it is you're doing or what
you've said or what story you've told it
what movie view made but you at the end
of the day don't get ownership of what
other people feel based off your things
and that is why I do think ultimately
artists intent does not matter very much
unless you're writing an academic paper
from the perspective of simply taking an
entertainment of watching or reading or
listening to a piece of art and having
it move you how it moves you is true for
you and it doesn't matter if that isn't
what the Creator intended the meaning
something else something different does
not invalidate what you experience what
you feel and unfortunately as I said
that can go in both directions that does
mean that people can take your art and
twist it into something awful that isn't
but also is on what you intended and
their ability to do that may or may not
be a reflection of a quality or the
issues with your piece of art but
ultimately they can and will do that
regardless of what you meant
I think the matrix is a good example of
that because at this point we know that
the witch house he's both of them are
transgender women and that and while
they haven't spoken specifically on that
it does seem to be very clear now that
the matrix the first one is very much a
trans narrative it's about someone who
sees himself not in the body in the
existence that he has who identifies
with another name the villain keeps he
keeps insisting on calling him by the
name that's on all of his documentation
is driver's license his birth
certificate
what's his big moment of defiance it's
saying to Agent Smith my name is neo it
is a trans narrative but at the same
time at the time that it came out there
were people who were not transgender who
saw this empowering fantasy of people
who felt misunderstood taking up arms
and taking down the system and that was
a message that could be twisted and
embraced by people who were very much
not the people
meant to be empowered by Fight Club very
much the same thing anyone who has ever
said to you that they think Tyler Durden
is awesome and he's an idol of theirs
they very much did not take Fight Club
as intended by David Fincher but saying
that to them doesn't suddenly mean that
what they felt watching it even if it's
a complete twisting of the original
artists intent it doesn't invalidate
that it is a via it may very well be a
viable reading of the piece of art or it
may indicate that the piece of art is
wildly misunderstood and if that's the
case could the artist have done more to
make it better understood maybe maybe
not but artists intent is for me it's
trivia I deal with the art as much as I
can and I and I say that even as someone
who actually doesn't separate the artist
from the art I don't necessarily believe
in that yet at the same time I will say
that artists intent doesn't matter
because I I do think that if you if you
are going to experience a piece of art
that ultimately all that matters is what
that art does for you how it speaks to
you what it says to you what message it
gives you and what the personal life or
triumphs or failings of or intent of the
artist was they're not part of the
equation anymore
ultimately when you experience a piece
of art there's only two things in that
relationship there's the art and there's
you that's it so that's kind of it I
think I don't have a perfectly worded
final button to end that on but on this
transgender day of visibility I wanted
to sort of go over this and and talk
this one out like I said it's a topic
I've been meaning to get to for a little
while now so again guys as I've said
last few times I've
I think it was only one of the time I
actually you know literally let my hair
down but as happened then I will remind
you I'm not suddenly gonna start doing
the channel looking like this this is
something that I did here on this
occasion because it is an occasion and
to mark the day so if you have curiosity
about this other side of my life if this
was news to you if you didn't see my Q&A
video from back early in the year I have
another YouTube channel called beer a
while there'll be a link down below
they'll be all the other links that
you're used to seeing like patreon and
Twitter and the podcast and all that
stuff so what are your thoughts on
artists intent creator intent
how much does it matter how much does
finding out what an artist meant with a
piece of art how much does that impact
your thoughts on it and your feelings
about it whatever your thoughts on this
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it if you're gonna
comment on this and how this kind of
threw you off fine you can go ahead and
do that just please don't be a jerk
about it even if you're confused just
don't be a jerk
so yeah that'll do it until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]